well I think people are going to drift
in and drift out in the course of the
afternoon and so I think we'll just make
this a very informal conversation and
I'm gonna begin by a few thoughts that I
have looking back at this story that
took place 30-plus years ago and involve
me to some extent one is about the
current view of the Mafia and the other
is about the writing of history three or
four well-known journalists have written
about Robert Kennedy and the Justice
Department and the same era and story
that I've written about Ronald Steele
did Arthur Schlessinger did having
thomas from newsweek recently sai Hirsch
and it's interesting that we have all
taken the same facts in the same story
and written different books and drawn
different conclusions from the same
facts quote unquote facts which raises
the question about what is a fact and
whether the writing of biography tells
us much about the author and the writer
as it does about the subject of the
biography one interesting thing about my
experience is that I was going to write
this book
in 1966 right after I left the Justice
Department when Robert Kennedy was
Attorney General and when all of this
was very fresh and he was going to write
the foreword to it and it was going to
be a very current history of the
experience we'd all had in the new
frontier I at the same time had been
offered a contract to write another book
on another subject about bail reform and
I wasn't sure which one I wanted to do
it seemed to me this was the time to
write the story of our recent
experiences and I went to New York and
talked to a young editor there who I'd
been introduced to and asked for his
advice he was with dial press at the
time and he said no by all means you
should write the bail book nobody else
is going to write that book you need
time to write this history you should
you should wait a period of time before
you do that I didn't agree really and I
didn't quite understand why he thought
that it seemed to me you write something
when it's fresh and
you get a better vision but for whatever
reason I did write the book about bail
and then Robert Kennedy was killed and
obviously wasn't going to write the
foreword and I put that one away and
thought I would never write it until
until many years later when a lot of the
people who were in the Justice
Department at that time came together at
the time of an HBO film about Robert
Kennedy and said you know you really
should write that book people are dying
and it's a great story it was one of the
highlights of the new frontier and you
should do it and so I did and the
interesting thing is so many disclosures
came about mostly as a result of the
church committee hearings in the 70s
about things that were going on in the
Justice Department while I was there but
about which I had no knowledge that in
fact it was a different book than I
might have written at the time it was
harder to go back and find some people
I even had difficulty finding the trial
records of the court proceedings in my
own cases but I did find them but the
interesting thing is that we found out
through the church committee and other
investigative reports that had come out
since then that things were going on at
the department that I didn't know about
particularly with regard to Fidel Castro
attempts to use the Mafia to assassinate
Castro and using the very people in some
cases that we were prosecuting and
investigating so the interesting PS is
that the editor of dial press who gave
me this advice was a doctor I went on to
become a great novelist of our time and
he was right even though I didn't think
so at the time it is a very different
book and it was a tricky book to write
because one doesn't want to make it too
autobiographical because people aren't
so much interested in knowing what I was
doing in 1964 but they're keenly and
endlessly interested in knowing what
Robert Kennedy was doing and you know
there was a Chinese saying may we live
in interesting times
those were very interesting times they
were very exciting times
the Kennedys brought a lot of glamour to
the Department of Justice working in the
government in those days was exciting
very interesting and in a way that seems
almost out of place nowadays altruistic
people weren't there to learn about the
government so they could go out and cash
in and work for a law firm and make a
lot of money the people were there
because they were turned on by what
different people in the administration
were doing particularly Robert Kennedy
also Sargent Shriver and the work that
he did in the Peace Corps drew out the
best in young people and even today i
represent Shriver who's writing his
memoir when I meet young people who are
in the Peace Corps their eyes glisten
about what it was then and and and there
is still that same feeling of commitment
and wanting to serve the country that I
don't think you see now in government
and I don't think you see in
administrations since the Kennedy years
so I'm glad I waited I'm glad I wrote
the book and there are a lot of
interesting things that happen then I
think the moment of the assassination of
JFK is a time that everybody who's alive
remembers exactly where they were and
what they were doing and that chapter in
this book I think is a particularly
interesting one because we were actually
in a meeting in Robert Kennedy's office
at the time that the assassination took
place he didn't know it but we had been
having one of our regular meetings to
discuss our cases with him we broke for
lunch and then of course he went to
Hickory Hill with guests from New York
Robert Morgenthau we went back to our
offices and then we all learned what had
happened and to me the incredible point
of of what happened is that while we
didn't know it at the time I
think the work that we were doing
fighting organized crime is what led to
the assassination of JFK after the
Warren Commission committee issued its
report Johnson said as much Robert
Kennedy said as much privately to people
he knew and the house assassination
committee which looked into it concluded
as much that it was it was trafficante
and marcelo and jimmy hoffa who had paid
to set up others to work with oswald and
that in in leading this charge that he
did robert kennedy and the organized
crime section had opened a Pandora's box
thought they could burn their candle at
both ends and both work with the mafia
at the same time that we were harassing
them and prosecuting them and
investigating them and making their
lives miserable and as a result I think
he went to his own death thinking that
he had been the cause of his brother's
death I'm not going to read from this
book I hope you all will read it
yourselves but if any of you have
questions about particular aspects of
those times I'm happy to answer those
questions and talk about what might be
on your minds
and if not that's okay too
when ye first came to Washington what
your views about working for Kennedy
well that's a it's a story that you know
but I was a young lawyer and was not
very high on Robert Kennedy in 1961 I
had supported Stevenson thought the
Kennedys were kind of pushy thought
Robert Kennedy had been an excessive
prosecutor when he ran McClellan
committee hearings and had great
reticence about him being Attorney
General I thought then I think now that
at the time he became Attorney General
he had no no qualifications to be
Attorney General he'd never practiced
law he didn't know anything except labor
racketeering which is why he came to the
Justice Department with organized crime
being his main interest I also think
that in the years he was Attorney
General he became he grew exponentially
he did even after he left the attorney
generalship and at the time of his death
that was a far different man and was
evolving into a great leader who was
unique in our history and had he lived
probably would have been president we
probably all would have been living in a
very different world I don't think they
would have been a Vietnam War they
surely wouldn't have been Watergate
there wouldn't have been a lot of the
Senate cynicism we now have about race
which is still a problem in this country
he had a credibility with the white
collar people he had a credibility with
blue-collar working-class people had a
credibility with the black community he
was tough prosecutor at the same time
but he was a soulful man who was touched
by the problems of farmworkers and
hunger in Mississippi and things of that
nature and these people believed in him
and so he had an interesting combination
of support that was unique and I don't
think equaled in the ear sense so I came
I thought for years stayed
for much longer and and changed my mind
dramatically during those years working
for him stayed in the Justice Department
the whole time he was there and went to
New York as a speechwriter when he ran
for the Senate left the government
thinking that there would be a time to
come back that we were going to be
seeing him again in higher office and
never had that opportunity yeah going
back to something you said in the
introduction and then I'm perhaps
misunderstood was there a connection
established I'm trying to dredge back
from years ago to remember a connection
established between Oswald and organized
crime
Oswald had connections with Ruby it's
been documented
I don't think Oswald sat in meetings
with mafia folks I think he was the
Patsy he said he was and was used I
think there is absolutely no question
that Oswald did not act alone and
whether he was used as a dupe or was
innocently used and so that the mob in
setting up the killing of Kennedy
wouldn't be seen to have done that and
in any event he was not acting alone I
think from the very moment the first
book after the assassination by Edward J
Epstein I think you obliterated the
single Bullet theory the conclusion of
the house assassinations committee with
their acoustical experts shows pretty
clearly that that there were other
shooters I don't think as well knew
those shooters I don't think even that
he necessarily knew that they were there
but they were there but it was set up
that I think that Oswald was recruited
by Ruby and knocked off by Ruby so that
he couldn't present any evidence and
there have been a lot of books that have
been written since including one by a
woman who had access to Cuban security
files which concluded
the same address this in your book a
chapter which is why I was saying before
had I written this book in 1966 I never
would have written a book I did the to
me that the the strangest thing of all
is if in fact Giancana and Marcello and
Trafficante and these people were behind
the killing of Kennedy how could it be
that he was pressing them at the same
time if we were using the mob as it's
clear we were in the anti-castro
escapades how did we think we were going
to get away with it yeah when we
indicted these people and you know
Giancana was represented by Edward
Bennett Williams and if in fact they had
this chip they could use Williams would
have presented it but I know from having
sat in on meetings that we were avid
about going after Giancana and all of
the others we know fairly definitely
from wiretaps that have been made public
in the years since then and which some
of which were in the report of the
church committees that there were
conversations between Hoffa Trafficante
and others about whacking out Kennedy
and the first the the first plan was to
kill Robert Kennedy and with there's
evidence and testimony and wiretaps of
conversations between the alleged
shooter Partin was his name from
Louisiana and Hoffa about shooting
Robert Kennedy and then the Mafia said
well if you do that and the president is
still the president then we're going to
have the Marines and everybody in the
world after us you can't if you want to
kill the snake you can't chop off its
tail you got to chop off its head and it
the assassination plan switched from a
plan to kill Robert Kennedy to a plan to
kill Jack Kennedy which is what happened
and again there are wiretaps and
conversations there's a book by
Trafficante and Hafez lawyer guy named
Morgan Oh in which he said that Hoffa
said you've got to get you got to go to
your your people go to traffic and you
got to tell them we've got to get this
guy
back we've got to kill him and then
after the assassination there they're
saying to reg I know go back and tell
your guy he owes us and it was this big
and the next thing you know there's a
team Stallone to Marcelo from the
Teamster pension fund I'm only giving
you a few of them but to say that this
is not just the semis of conspiracy
conspiracy theorists I'm talking about
but but an extraordinary amount of
circumstantial evidence admissions by
people themselves which would be
admissible in court if there was a trial
now including Marcelo trafficante
oregano Parton Hoffa and others about
the plan to do this even if even if that
never happened even if that plan never
happened because the an isolated act by
Oswald intervened and the Mafia's
stepped back and said wow we don't have
to do it
there was still a conspiracy to kill the
president and there were over at acts
and furtherance of the conspiracy so
that as a former prosecutor I would say
there was enough evidence to avert a
conspiracy case against it even if there
was no connection at all between Oswald
and people and the mob though I think it
was why was it never done conspiracy
well I mean first of all at the time the
Warren Commission reached its
conclusions because the Warren
Commission was basing its conclusions on
the evidence that was presented to it
they had the FBI and the CIA or both of
which were feathering their own nest in
terms of of what they wanted to be made
public and what would be embarrassing to
them there was no way and the CIA had a
member of the Warren Commission so the
Warren Commission was acting like
McNamara was acting about Vietnam bright
people taking the evidence before them
drawing a perfectly appropriate
conclusion but if the evidence is wrong
you draw their own conclusions
so the Warren Commission did
have the information subsequently
different people were dead and you know
Giancana was killed shortly before he
testified before the house assassination
committee shot in the neck and mouth
which is the month the Mafia's way of
saying you'll never speak again and
trafficante died Hoffa was in prison
Hoffa and and Marcello tried to bribe
witnesses to get half a head of prison
to say that the testimony against him
was false so they were they were the
people were never together at the same
time that the evidence was accumulated
and and and the evidence still can
continues to build will probably never
have the decisive evidence that we might
have it'll be interesting to see when
Fidel Castro dies and those records are
completely made public some have been to
see what would happen but there were
there were these plots and plans going
on right up until the very moment of the
assassination somebody from the CIA was
meeting in Paris with a Cuban who they
were using to kill Castro and three days
before the assassination Castro said to
an AP reporter at a meeting in Havana I
know that they're trying to get me and
if they get me it's their leaders are
going to be gotten as well so all of
this stuff was going on roughly at the
same time but but but none of it was
known when the Warren Commission issued
its reports
do you think the Warren Commission
report the best job they could have her
I knew the people who were working I
think they were earnest I don't think I
don't think I think I think I think the
CIA representative and the FBI sources
of information were controlled by Hoover
and Helms at the CIA and they knew they
the you know a handful of people at CIA
very few knew what it was that they were
doing there's no way in the world that
that was going to come out then didn't
the Commission decide that Oswald acted
alone by himself yes and their
timetables that as I recall are
completely asked you getting him across
town and under tunnels to the movie
theater and at a mock pace that with a
police car behind him wouldn't have
known to pick him up it reads there they
were in a rush Johnson didn't want the
world to perceive this country is coming
apart because a popular internationally
popular president had been killed so he
quickly convened these people and tried
a group that would have a lot of
credibility and told them to get this
thing done and to as well as possible
not to dissemble but to to get it done
so that it could be behind this country
that we were all grieving people were
mystified you have to remember that now
those of us now who've lived the last 30
40 years have seen the Pope shot we've
seen Martin Luther King shot we've seen
Kennedy killed these things seem
commonplace in a nasty world that we
live in at the time it was unthinkable
it was like unimaginable and so it was
there was a great concern in bringing
the country to some composure and to
have the international community know
that things were in charge and this
country wasn't in chaos so
ideally and not for bad purposes there
was a rush to get this thing done and
the very committee was relying for its
information on sources which weren't
going to give them the evidence that
they knew and also it wasn't until later
on that some of these things ever came
to light so I think they probably came
out with an earnest conclusion and I
think now there's a vested interest in
keeping the case closed and and not
going back people say you know to what
purpose
should we open this you know what do we
gain by it they've been something like
2,000 books written about it one
hesitates to crawl into that thicket
because a lot of them are bizarre
notions but if you sort through the
evidence it's hard to conclude that it's
impossible to conclude I think that that
Oswald was acting alone we have I have
seen there's a brood of film one of my
partners represented them and I actually
sat and watched the actual film of it
and you look at that and you can't you
can't believe that it was one person
acting alone you see and going like this
you see them going back it if you see
the real thing as opposed to the few
segments that most people have seen it's
almost impossible and then when you put
that together with the acoustical
evidence that the house assassination
committee came up with and the
circumstantial evidence of the people
five people who were who were
interviewed but later evidence that
comes from the Cuban records from the
CIA records that have been disclosed the
wiretaps that were put together by the
house assassination committee all of it
builds kind of circumstantial evidence
that I think is irresistible points to
the conclusion that that there were more
people than Oz well there and and those
people were either the mob or Cubans who
were being used by the mob
don't you think there's some value them
in having the American population say or
believe in a more common way that Oswald
didn't act on if you ask the person on
the street who killed Kennedy the person
will probably say Oswald but given all
this evidence and given all the reports
that are available to people and and the
voice the heights and so many people's
heads it it was impossible he acted
alone no matter who his partners were
don't you think it's valuable for people
to ultimately say Kennedy was killed by
Oswald and I think if we had a little
more decisive information about who
those others are it would probably make
sense even at this late date for some
blue-ribbon Commission or joint
congressional investigator a group there
was an assassination records committee
that that met a few years ago and when
further records were opened up but some
of the family rec because of the the
family there were some records that
aren't going to be open until 50 years
after Kennedy was killed which is
getting a little close so I think it's
as remote as it is I think it is
possible still that there might be some
kind of proceeding it's not going to be
a trial but it might be a hearing that
would complete the historical record and
when that's done I think it's going to
be clear that that it was more than then
been Oswald alone
what's the main difference between
fighting organized crime in nineteen
sixty three or four and fighting it
today would he do the same but is it the
same process just different tools Cruz
has it changed qualitatively it's
something it's changed but it's not so
dissimilar I just finished reading a
book about a huge case in New York
that's only two or three years old
involving the waste disposal unions you
know the the Sanitation business which
which was a huge indictment of over 40
or 50 people they had some undercover
folks and there was something like a
fight it was a 500 million dollar
business and it was run by the mobs and
all over New York so it still goes on
the Mafia as it existed in 1960 however
where you really had almost a corporate
structure and jurisdictions divided up
and you know Marcelo running the south
and different people in New York New
England where they actually met they had
you know turf identifications of what
they were doing that's not the case now
it's much more and it's not just the
Italian mafia which does still exist it
is you have the drug business which is
run by central latin americans you've
got a Vietnamese gangs in California
you've got Russian mafia in New York and
they all have nothing to do with each
other whereas the organized crime of
1960 really was an organization one last
point I would make before we run out of
time and to me I'm amused and horrified
at the same time by the kind of mythic
proportions and acculturation of the
Mafia nowadays I don't understand the
popularity of The Sopranos I don't I
mean I do understand the amusement of
analyze this and analyze that it's hard
not to see that movie and think it's
funny
but I don't get the Sopranos I don't get
America thinking that these people are
somehow rather these cute folks in the
neighborhood
there's no socially redeeming purpose
there you know they're ugly violent
people who are out to corrupt public
officials to destroy institutions unions
white-collar businesses or wherever they
go and somehow or other from the era of
the Godfather forward we've had so many
interesting dramatizations of different
aspects of the Mafia which are hard to
not like I watched a segment of the one
of the old Godfather's last night but
the literature is seeped in and somehow
or other there's been a distance between
the literature and fiction of the Mafia
and the reality the reality then and the
reality now is ugly unredeemable and I
think we forget that at our peril so
thank you all for coming when there's
all that good football going on and
cocktail parties and whatnot nice to see
some familiar faces